my channel is sponsored by virtual one
which means you will have an ad read
from them somewhere in the middle of
this video I touched on this in my q a
yesterday but it wasn't enough in case
you missed it there's a whole bunch of
drama surrounding Boulder's Gate 3
um no small part of which involves two
people that I am friends with who I
don't think know each other but are
definitely disagreeing with each other
one of them is Indie Dev zalavi and
Nelson Jr whom I'm very fond of I think
he's awesome the other one is IGN's
Destin legary who we worked with for
many years and are very fond of and
think is awesome these two people have
very very different takes that I have
not yet viewed all of so we're going to
dive into that today as well as just
talk about Baldur's Gate 3 in general I
personally am very confident that
Baldur's Gate 3 is going to end up being
my game of the year I've barely
scratched the surface I still feel like
I don't know what the [__] I'm doing
thing that I very much like about it but
unless it's not your kind of video game
which I think is totally acceptable and
very possible for a lot of people this
is quite a deep RPG but I do feel like
it is
undeniably incredible quality and I
desperately hope it makes a lot of money
because at the core of of this
conversation I think and we'll get
further into it is Publishers the game
makes a bunch of money Publishers will
see it making a bunch of money and be
like hey do that and then maybe the dev
Studios get to go give us seven years
which like only a very small handful of
Studios can currently get away with uh
without the publisher being like
absolutely not you have to release it on
this day when it's potentially not even
ready on whatever date that is and you
only have this amount of money there is
no money left some fun statistics uh to
back up the quality of of Bowlers Gate 3
which like personally I have pretty
frequent frame rate drops the loading
screens are very long but for the most
part I think the direction of this game
is just incredible they've nailed every
single thing that they intended to nail
they knew what the assignment was and
they stuck to it and that's something
that I think is so important for
crafting like a very good experience but
the thing that gets me really
enthusiastic about it is the amount of
choice I imagine if I would have watched
somebody do the goblin cave that I just
played through last night failed by the
way I I just was like I gotta leave and
come back here later I'm not ready for
this that I would see something
completely different to what I did and I
love that in an RPG I feel like so many
games want to do that but do not have
the time or budget to do it Baldur's
Gate 3 just nailed it I do think this
game is like
mind-blowingly fantastic and that is
supported by the data balder's Gate 3 is
currently the highest rated game on
Metacritic of 2023 higher even than the
Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
this plot sign a Boulders Gate 3 also
accounted for nearly 28 of total player
time spent on the entirety of steam
leading all other titles including CS go
which is only at five percent this is
nuts like so unbelievably impressive on
open critic uh which is a very similar
place to Metacritic uh it is the highest
rated game of all time it is literally
number one they hit over 800 000
concerned players on Steam the 10 most
popular games of all time on Steam dude
damn and yeah PlayStation 5 launch is
coming September 6 which for reference
I'm currently logic playing the game on
control of people have been asking me
about it a lot and it changes the uh
perspective so for the people wondering
about playing it on PS5 I think you're
gonna be totally fine um it makes combat
a little bit slower but frankly I've
played this game so slowly anyway
because I'm thinking so much about
everything by choice I think I would do
all exploration on controller and then
swap to mouse and keyboard for combat
which you could do on a PS5 as well but
yes I think you're going to be great
running the PS5 version and that's part
of this that I think is also really
important is like this game being the
quality that it is there are so many
more Studios this is certainly a thing
that happened to CD project red where
everyone who was playing the game early
and previewing it was talking about it
really positively because we were
playing PC build obviously launch uh the
quality dropped a little bit even from
the previews but it was still reviewed
really well by people who played it on
PC because it ran well on PC that game
never should have come out on Console
the same day what baldus Gate 3 has done
and what larian has done is just delay
the other versions until they're ready
so the PC version had three years Early
Access that is three years of bug fixes
effectively a large beta test that's
what Early Access really is get it to
the point where it is now and they had
nobody telling them that they had to
release it on Playstation or Xbox on the
same day so PS5 is scheduled for
September 6 and I have no doubt that
they would just push it if it wasn't
ready and then I believe they said Xbox
would be like some point later down the
line like whenever it's ready to do that
and that's just the dream for so many
Dev Studios like the truth is virtually
every Dev Studio wants to be able to do
that just not a lot of them can't
Publishers like nope get it out you got
to get it out right now you gotta get in
this day we gotta make our money back by
this time because of the stock market
and the shareholders and I love that
this is walking and I so badly hope that
these console versions are also really
polished again so that the Baldur's Gate
3 win can like literally help the whole
industry like every Dev Studio gets to
be like see if you just give us a little
more time so clearly
game is
fantastic
the audience consensus is that it is
extremely popular the critic consensus
is that it is fantastic why is that
drama so I think this Twitter thread is
what kicked it off
um I've seen people say multiple devs
have said negative things about Baldur's
Gate 3
um Austin mentioned that to me on player
watch listen I wasn't actually able to
find any of that as also said on my q a
maybe it exists somewhere I couldn't
find any of it I've in fact only found
Dev saying extremely positive things
about uh Baldur's Gate 3. so this is the
Twitter thread from zelavia Nelson Jr uh
again he's quite well known in the Indie
space he is not a triple A Game Dev but
I have not read this thread which I
think is kicked off some of this
controversy so let's do that so the
thread says like a lot of people I'm
deeply excited about what the lovely
Folks at larian accomplished with
Baldur's Gate 3 but I want to gently
preemptively push back against players
taking that excitement and using it to
apply criticism or a raised standard to
RPGs going forward which
immediately I probably would not have
used that sentence I I definitely
understand why people are upset about
that phrasing I think telling Gamers
that they shouldn't have high standards
uh uh is never going to go down well
um and is also unfair but at the same
time this sounds like a pretty realistic
take he said you can't separate a game
from the process used to build it so
let's look at what larian is taking into
the development of the final version of
the game one a Dev cycle stretching back
to 2017 two massive games and their
definitive editions worth of tech and
institutional knowledge to draw from
super successful Early Access period
lasted three years providing crucial
Community feedback bug hunting and cash
flow also true over 400 developers in
seven offices around the world that's so
nuts man like it's just so 400
developers is a lot to be clear most AAA
game studios don't even have 400
developers if you're not including
Outsourcing Partners licensor brand in
the world of one of the largest
entertainment IPS in the world DND at
the Apex of its popularity with the rise
of the actual play movement and movies
this is a small incomplete list layering
is coming into this game Swinging with a
gigantic weight of expectation to deal
with but they're also doing it with an
immense amount of win direct experience
resources specialty tooling Etc at their
backs the tldr in the era of Mega games
bald Skate 3 is one of the largest
attempted built by a specialized group
of people you using mature attack
specially built to make this specific
game reinforced by invaluable Mass
player feedback and Market validation
ahead of its launch that is objectively
true this is not only Baseline for RPGs
this is an anomaly trying to do the same
thing in the same way especially without
the advantages could kill an entire
group of Studios this is also true while
the Skate 3 is an anomaly I once again
can understand why people are pushing
back against this because it shouldn't
be and that's the truth Baldur's Gate 3
shouldn't be an normal it shouldn't be
the case that it could kill an entire
group of Studios but it could people
have probably attempted to make things
just like bald Escape 3 many times and
failed larion has a fantastic talented
team who had time and money on their
side I'm sure they had a ton of
struggles making this game as good as is
I don't want anyone to take that away
from them it has to have been incredibly
hard I first previewed the game like
years ago it was like three or four
years ago that I saw Baldur's Gate 3
which is the longest time I've ever seen
between playing a game as media and the
game coming out which to me indicates
that they were allowed to wait they were
allowed to hold off releasing the game
obviously while it was in Early Access
until it was ready that's the pot that's
the anomaly and the pot that sucks and
the part that I wish players would take
away from this it is time to talk about
the virtual one the world's first XR
glasses designed for gamers this is the
device right here and it is so
unbelievably cool basically you put
these glasses on connected to your
switch they also have a mount for if you
want to connect it to mobile and the one
I'm currently using works with switch
and steam deck you pick from a couple of
different nose pads put them on adjust
the lenses to suit your face took me
maybe 20 seconds to do and then you have
inside of these glasses a pixel free
1080 60 frames a second screen this is
so impressive I can't believe the screen
quality I guess it's not a screen it's
XR but it's like perfect quality there's
also a button for color changing film so
you can change the background Darkness
without affecting the brightness of a
screen plus you can change the screen
brightness change the audio and I will
say the audio is really really good the
speakers are basically just hiding like
here on the sides of the glasses they
partnered with Harman for that I know
and another incredibly cool thing about
it is that it allows for Co-Op I'm
currently I don't know if you can see it
in there see how tiny it looks but
obviously it's a big screen uh first
thing I wanted to try was Zelda but if
you have two pairs of glasses you can
connect them both to the same system and
you can play co-op with the glasses it
also has an extra battery for the switch
and the steam deck so if you want to get
yours click the link in the description
and use code Alana to get 10 off your
very own virtual one glasses like some
of the tweets that I've seen floating
around about this people saying oh look
game devs making excuses because players
expect good game games or like game devs
are just lazy like there are so many of
those that just fundamentally
misunderstand and I said this in a video
yesterday and even even then people were
like clearly this isn't true because
look at the state of this game I don't
think there's a single Dev Studio on the
planet outside of the ones that are like
objectively Shuffle wear scams like um
those PlayStation rip-off games that I
covered recently there is no devs you
don't it wants anything other than to
make a good game what I just said is not
controversial it is not a hot take you
should not take it as such it is just a
fact and if you'd come back to me and
say Well then why the game broken the
reason that Games come out broken and I
really think this happened to cyberpunk
is not because of the dev team I promise
you when you work on something for five
seven ten years it's your legacy it's
your life all you care about is that
thing being good it consumes you for
years and years and years and it's hard
and it's frustrating and all you want is
for it to work and be good and for
people to like it otherwise you do
[__] anything else so I know it
sounds like a basic take but a lot of
people clearly still don't know the
reason that Games come out in any lesser
state is not because game devs don't
care or are lazy trust me they want to
make the best game possible it's because
they have a publisher they have to
answer to and there's nothing that they
can do about them if a publisher says
Nope this has to come out this month
this quarter which is usually because
the publisher is answering to the stock
market or to shareholders who will
literally pull their money out if they
don't get a return on investment after a
certain amount of time and thus like you
could literally shut the whole company
down the publisher mandates the date and
the devs do their very very best to get
the thing in the best quality possible
before that date budget is also a huge
thing that is not something the dev
Studio controls they just have like all
of these pieces and they have certain
people with certain skill sets and
people can still quit and leave whenever
they want to and they just all come
together and a publisher says this
amount of money by this time go and part
of why you know you're not being a new
Baseline for RPGs being an anomaly which
again I think is true even though it is
like objectively shitty part of this
conversation I always want to talk about
is that it's objectively shitty for the
gamers and the devs the ideal here would
be that devs who are often also angry at
their Publishers but aren't allowed to
say so and gamers are on the same team
versus the Publishers because there's
all this weird discourse there where
like the gamers hate the journalists the
journalists hate the devs the devs hate
the game it's like it's just such a bad
landscape when really the big bad
publisher is like off having a great
time because all these people are
squabbling amongst each other that
people have no actual control those
people would Unified
put pressure on the people who actually
make the decisions I feel like the whole
industry would be way better off very
convenient for them that that's not what
happens this is what makes bald Escape 3
an anomalies that they seemingly did not
have that same amount of pressure that a
lot of AAA Dev Studios have again also
not taking away their incredible amounts
of experience the fact that the games
they make it goes beyond that like I
view them in the same league as I view
like from soft and platinum at this
point like it is a part of it that's
being spoken about here and it is the
undeniable part of it but it is also
just like they clearly have an excellent
very experienced team of brilliant
designers and Brilliant directors who
know exactly what they're doing and are
so good at executing it I really don't
want to take that away from my point is
not to discredit larion at all it's more
just to fight against the notion that
every other Dev is bad or lazy when that
is like objectively not the case sorry
to continue the Tweet threat if they go
bigger or better with their next title
layering themselves could die that's the
recent reward of a mega game also true
we're in an industry dangling elephants
overclips pointing at the ones that
don't collapse under their own weight as
indictments to the ones that do so
please celebrate the achievement
represented by Baldur's Gate 3 it looks
like a massive amount of effort is about
to pay off in a big way for one of the
brightest voices in the medium beautiful
thing to say he's right but if you shout
every RPG should be like this going
forward you have no excuse you said
you've not just missed the point you've
created the expectations and conditions
to ensure your favorite creators may
never be able to give you the thing you
love ever again Dan so then I did watch
like the first minute of Destin's video
on IGN so let me look that up again
Destin also a friend and this headline
is Ballers Gate 3 is causing some
developers to panic let's watch it
Baldur's Gate 3 is taking the Internet
by storm at its peak a whopping 800 000
plus concurrent players The Gaming
Community has sung its praises and it's
incredibly refreshing to play a feature
complete game of this caliber on day one
but AAA game developers want you to know
that this is Rockstar level nonsense for
scope I gotta read this one I would not
be surprised if this was more Dev epic
than the next two or three games in the
genre combined it's rock style level
nonsense for scope only a few Studios
could even try this I cannot wait to
play about this kind of effort likely
would be replicated this decade again I
wish people would phrase things
just just a little more thoughtfully is
it Rockstar level nonsense for scope
probably it is an amount of scope that
most Studios aren't allowed to pursue
right became so this is a great Thread
about by using a singular game to set
expectations for everyone developing
titles in a genre isn't useful and is
instead foolhardy that it's foolhardy to
set expectations higher and Baldur's
Gate 3 should not be used as a raise
standard to RPGs going forward why was
the first response to defend the current
state of AAA gaming as opposed to saying
hey maybe we can learn a thing or two
from Baldur's Gate 3 and make our game
better for our customers can I give you
just like one like real Insider thing
when every new AAA game comes out devs
play them you know dev's a game is too
right and then they all go to work the
next day and be like we should do
something more like Alden ring that's
like a meme for game devs is that
everybody goes to the office while
playing Elder ring and then pitches
everything to do with eldering trust me
it is so well known that every Dev ever
is currently playing Baldur's Gate 3 and
pitching systems from Boulder Skate 3
for the game they're working on I
promise it's literally an industry meme
are we really going to pretend that
consumers shouldn't be a little upset
right now and hoping for an improvement
in the industry going forward no
rockstar just announced that pot
distance 100 right you should have race
standards and you should you should
demand better you should
um it just doesn't necessarily do
anything that's the problem
capitalism 50 remake I'm sorry
conversion of the original Red Dead
Redemption for the PlayStation 4 and
switch that has no mention of a 4K
update
and no mention of multiplayer support
but yeah
you know who's to blame for the Red Dead
Redemption 2 switch Port not Rockstar
Rockstar didn't work on it Rockstar
didn't have anything to do with it take
two it's the publisher remember that
tweet was made nearly a month before
Baldur's Gate 3 blew up and it was still
contentious with bands speaking up about
their frustrations and developers
chiming in to say what felt like game
development is hard you don't get it be
quiet Baldur's Gate three everybody said
that from a live instrument Studio that
refuses to add microtransactions again
refuses to add microtransactions as a
plus I would have a lot of trouble
working on a game without micro
transactions that is a massive privilege
and anomaly again right like that is a
huge when Valerian that I'm sure a lot
of Studios would love to have it doesn't
work that way if your publisher tells
you you have to have microtransactions
the alternative is you [__] get shut
down look Dustin is 100 right in that uh
players should always expect more and I
very strongly think that players should
expect more and I disagree with any Dev
who would share the sentiment that
players should expect less I think
players should ask for more and I do
think that repeatedly Games should be
held accountable uh when things do not
meet player expectations that I do think
that people should be loud about it I
don't think it's something that should
just be tolerated but I also think that
Destin has missed the point a little bit
here devs can hold himself to whatever
high standard they want
um and can take whatever inspiration
they want and can try to make the best
thing on the planet that doesn't give
them more budget doesn't give them more
staff and it doesn't give them more time
which are the things that I really
needed to make a video game